if you just bought a car in america
there's a roughly two percent chance
that it's an electric vehicle but that
number could be about to change i'm
announcing steps we're taking set a new
pace for electric vehicles what you're
seeing here is the leaders of major
automakers making a voluntary commitment
to 40 to 50 percent of all vehicles sold
by 2030 in america being electric it's a
big deal it is a big deal battery
electric vehicles made up just over one
percent of all of ford's u.s sales in
the first half of 2021. it's going to
take a lot of things to fall in place to
convince americans to go 50 electric you
see right now evs are in a bit of a
chicken and egg cycle sales are low
partly because of a lack of charging
infrastructure and part of the reason
there's a lack of charging
infrastructure is because ev sales are
low i'm not sure which is the chicken or
the egg but you get the idea so to try
and break that cycle and meet climate
change targets biden is pushing to
invest in ev charging networks as part
of his 1 trillion infrastructure bill
we're going to need a lot more charging
stations and infrastructure now even
though that bill isn't signed yet it's
already impacting automakers decisions
and could have a profound effect on
america's roads within the decade but
what could that future look like well i
work for the wall street journal and i'm
lucky enough to have access to some of
our reporters who can provide a bit of a
window into what we might see and how
likely it is to become a reality i need
to head into the office and i'm going to
give one of them a call i'm root let's
go
you're supposed to come with me let's go
[Music]
now i don't normally drive to work but i
want to introduce you to susie
this is susie
she's my relatively new car and she's
really good example of that chicken egg
charging scenario even here in the uk
you see i looked at getting an ev but i
regularly make single trips of over 200
miles for my job as a video
correspondent and also for leisure i
have family in the north and when i
compared that against range charging
time and charger availability i realized
i couldn't always be sure i'd be able to
get where i needed to be when i needed
to be there so i bought a hybrid instead
and analysts say i am not alone in the
us the number of ev charging stations is
less than a third of the number of
gasoline stations and that's resulted in
some consumers having concerns around
charging it's part of the reason why ev
adoption in the u.s has been slower than
in europe or in china both of which have
more charging stations than the us but
times are changing according to a pew
research survey 39 of americans said
they would consider making their next
car an ev
so how could biden's infrastructure bill
change that well if there's one person
who knows the answer it's autos reporter
ben foldy he's been covering this pretty
extensively and i'm going to give them a
call right now
hey george hey ben how's it going good
how are you yeah not bad i'm just
driving into the office i wanted to ask
you about biden's infrastructure bill
and what it means for ev charges yeah so
the compromise bill
has about seven and a half billion set
aside for ev infrastructure
um that's about half of what the
president originally proposed when the
funding was tied to this
a number of 500 000 new public chargers
so it's likely more about half of half a
million at this point right and is that
enough charges for those automakers to
hit those 50 sales targets um no the
investment bank cowan says that the u.s
will need about 11 million charges by
2030. they expect 8 million of that will
be going to people's homes and garages
but they still say that the country will
need about 1.5 million new public
chargers and all in all they see the
total investment in charging
infrastructure costing about 44 billion
uh so the biden plans goal isn't to
provide every single charger that's
going to be needed it's about kind of
kick-starting the development of this
industry will generate historic job
growth historic economic growth it's
about changing consumer perception and
it's also about equity the biden
administration thinking about this is
kind of like well okay if we want the
whole country to transition to evs you
know we need to support charging in
places where it might not otherwise go
there's kind of an effort to detach it
from the car companies and kind of
universalize it right and if that
investment happens what will america
look like are we talking about a rapidly
different us i think the hope is that
the change will be fairly rapid but i
think what's likely is kind of less an
eevee invasion and more like an eevee
infiltration it's unlikely that the us
leapfrogs the eu and china um just given
those you know the head starts held by
those those places
as i've said before we're in competition
with china and many other nations for
the 21st century if this is a race right
like i mean it's definitely a concerted
effort to catch up i might not overtake
but you know at least wants to be in the
pack okay ben uh i'm just pulling into
the office so i'm going to say goodbye
there but thanks for everything man
catch you later bye
so will ev sales hit 50 by 2013 well as
ford's ceo says building charging
infrastructure is only part of the
battle we're gonna have to have consumer
um incentives to make it financially
less burdensome to transition which
brings us back to susie because if i'm
being completely honest there's another
reason why i bought the hybrid version
and not the electric version and that's
because i couldn't afford the electric
version so if automakers want to hit
those sales targets they're going to
have to hit the right price point too
hey one last thing from me if you're
really interested in the future of
mobility and how we get from a to b then
don't forget to subscribe and also if
you want to read more of ben's work then
i've left a link below
[Music]